il s'appelait mario gonzalez c'était ce
lundi 19 avril pendant plus de cinq
minutes
l'homme de 26 ans citoyen d'alameda près
de san francisco est plaqué au sol par
plusieurs policiers
la scène s'est déroulée suite à un appel
au 911 qui a alerté les agents de la
présence d'un homme ivre dans un parc de
la ville
des images qui rappellent celles de
georges floyd assassiné le 25 mai 2020
les conséquences sont similaires puisque
l'intervention musclée des policiers a
coûté la vie de mario gonzalez son frère
dirige ne comprend toujours pas ce qui
m'a réellement frappé c'est tout
simplement les fausses informations
qu'on nous a données on nous a dit qu'il
était mort en état d'arrestation durant
le trajet vers l'hôpital et qui
l'emmenait à l'hôpital pour qu'il soit
réanimer
la vidéo montre une histoire réellement
différente vers 19h30
toute personne ayant du bon sens se
demandera comment quelqu'un n'ayant pas
de pathologies préexistantes peut subir
une urgence médicale soudaine à l'âge de
26 ans et en mourir
au loin
[Musique]
nous voulons que les agents impliqués
soient tenus pour responsables ainsi
qu'une enquête complète et impartiale
sur la politique de formation et
d'encadrement de ces agents en attendant
d'autres affaires similaires à celles de
mario gonzalez se multiplient aux etats
unis le 21 avril dernier un afro
américain de 41 ans andrew brown a été
tué d'une balle dans la nuque au cours
d'une arrestation en caroline du nord ce
mardi un rapport d'autopsié indépendant
présenté par ses proches a estimé que
l'homme avait été exécuté par les forces
de police
la fréquence des violences policières
n'a pas diminué depuis l'arrivée de joe
biden au pouvoir selon blacklight moteur
le mouvement de défense communautaire
fondé en 2013 a publié un communiqué sur
son site web
ils réclament notamment la fin du
programme 1033 qui permet le transfert
d'équipements militaires excédentaire
aux forces de l'ordre locales une
situation qui terrorise selon lui les
communautés noires
le mouvement dénonce une véritable
militarisation de la police encore plus
rapide que pendant la mandature de
donald trump plus de 7 milliards de
dollars ont été versés aux forces de
l'ordre depuis la création du programme
1033 sous l'administration clinton
de manière assez décevante le flux
d'équipements militaires vers la police
dans le cadre du programme 1033 s'est
accélérée sous l'administration byden
aucun dirigeant responsable ne devrait
augmenter les armes auxquelles la police
a accès et si le président mbaye donne
ce souci d innombrables noir qui se sont
mobilisés pour le mettre au pouvoir il
le reconnaître est si nous voulons que
le présent byden prennent des mesures
rapides avant le centième jour de son
mandat il faut que de nombreuses voix
s'exprime dès maintenant
de son côté joe biden a appelé le sénat
à adopter dès le mois de mai un projet
de réforme des forces de l'ordre une
disposition qui devrait permettre selon
le locataire de la maison blanche de
lutter contre l'immunité judiciaire des
agents de police qu'il estime trop
importante